cast out the afternoon session where
famous morons from Cornell talking about
is really interesting CD by project
thanks you and thanks the organizers for
this chance to come talk about this work
here and have a great time the rest of
the week as well so bike sharing systems
are starting to be a regular part of the
urban landscape there are really at this
point hundreds of cities in which such a
system is present so what is a bike
sharing system for those of you might
not have encountered it um it's a in
this case as a map of Manhattan with a
footprint of stations you see a state
one such station in the background
behind that map of a collection of docs
on the one hand and bikes filling those
those stations oh man a rider can pick
up a bike at any given station and
return it to any other station of his or
her choosing oh and of course what no
there's a cell phone mystica and it's
dicaprio now and actually lets you know
truth in advertising so there are two
city bike systems one in miami and one
in New York the key is all you can tell
for the vegetation the one in Miami
mouth or what in New York the main
operational challenge so there are many
operational challenges in running a bike
sharing system is that of imbalance that
on the one hand you can see a station
left where a writer is trying to about
to return his bike and it's not clear
where he's going to pick it up and on
the other hand the woman on the Rights
is seized nothing but empty docks oh man
you get you know when you when you work
with companies like this you get you
know I rate messages like the following
that's a literal one that even when I
just now have the associated this came
to my email account not even to to the
city FICO you know check out the
problems so to give you a
a day in the life of a bike sharing
system I'm going to play you a movie now
this is a couple years old so it's not
accurate for the the current time but
it'll give you a feel for the way things
are you'll see of the upper left there
there'll be a clock that tells you on
the 24-hour time so we're going to start
@midnight when things are pretty
quiescent that for each station the
volume and a given short time interval
will be depicted in terms of the net
flow by the diameter and if its net flow
departing it'll be read if its net flow
or writhing it'll be blue and let's go
to the video
so it's you know this is the city that
never sleeps indeed you still see even
in the wee hours of the morning some
scattered activity with not without any
real sense of pattern to it but now it's
getting to be 6 and all of a sudden the
city comes to life that you see a lot of
red here in the East Village a lot of
blue here in the financial district the
traders are waking up and to taking
their bike and going to work it's now
ten o'clock things are calming down oh
that now comes lunchtime and there's a
little bird burst of activity and the
patterns of what's blue and what's red
somewhat different now lunchtime has
faded it's it's calm or a bit and now
we're picking up into the rush hour by
four o'clock things really start to be
heavily and notice that it's the
asymmetric version that that the
financial district is red in the East
Village is blue but there are
interesting anomalies that it's still
pretty heavy till about eight o'clock
and then we back it back down to the
evening oh and a little by little we can
make our way back to midnight when
things are now calming down a bit so
this is this is as I said a bit old but
but what really gives you a flavor for
for the way things are and things
haven't really changed to give you an
order of magnitude of scale last month
the month of May there were more than
1.2 million trips taken oh there are
depends how honest I want to be there is
something like over that month of May
the number of bikes in service went from
6,000 up till about seven thousand over
the course of month over the course of
that month I'm not at liberty to tell
you why there was that gradient there
but well I can tell that they had some
issues with maintenance and they had to
pull a two thousand bikes off the road
and at the beginning of April all to do
systematic repairs for a very troubling
reason but that's all but that's all
behind Oh
so there are there so so let's say today
there are something like seven thousand
bikes on the road there are something
like 14 and a half thousand docks at
roughly 400 slightly plus stations in
the current footprint so you'll see map
more current maps that there is a good
swath of Brooklyn and a little piece of
Queens that that's currently there and
when I was there two weeks ago there are
rumors that it will be expanded to be
fully citywide but that's a substantial
capital investment and they're
interesting discussions as to where that
capital will will come come from
Columbia I I would be astonished if it
isn't there in June I mean not this gym
but you know make a year from now a year
from now all there and and yeah yes so
you good so you know sort of heaviest
you know sort of keep your points of
thinking about this data I mean one of
the nice things about these systems is
that we have a complete record of
everything that happens so when it when
a boy here we go in a user to use the
system you know has this pass that you
stick into the dock it releases the bike
so it records your ID is embedded in
this so you the system knows the idea of
the person using that bike it has an ID
for the bike that is dock that has an
RFID chip in the handlebar tube
structure of the bike there's a doc ID
so we know exactly you know which bike
is being removed from which stock at a
given station and and at what time and
then contrary to rumors there has never
been GPS devices on at least the cities
by New York City spikes so the only
thing that we know is when that bike
then re-emerges at another station and
get stalked in and indeed sometimes it's
not surprising it guess doesn't ever
really the person's credit card gets
charged a hefty chunk of change
um okay so so we we no no okay even
though its billing data it is still not
a hundred percent reliable but it's
pretty good it's yeah so most trips are
by computing if you buy commuters that's
not just boast that's not the same thing
as saying that most trips are commuting
which is still true but indeed commute
people who use it regularly for
commuting then also use it for
additional trips throughout the day so
it's not unusual to see a person making
on the order of 20 trips a week as
opposed to just the 10 are commuting
trips that you would expect yeah when
you say mr. Spock commuters so we
believe that they're taking it from
their residence or far from their
residence or some transit point on their
travel to ending up at work and and
because of no timing information it
occurs you know somewhere between six
and ten a.m. and then we see
symmetrically from that leaving from one
of the stations near where they docked
it in in pretty much the reverse
direction that's so that's what I mean
as you saw on the the movie the heaviest
use is between six and ten a.m. in the
morning and between four and eight pm
what's not immediately visible but but
what the data shows is that it's heavier
in the afternoon by and large than it is
in the morning that's a baby not so
surprising people don't want to arrive
sweaty to work and all depending on the
particular commuter did may actually be
slightly less efficient some places that
that big I mean one of the big corridors
is that east village to the financial
district that probably is the other than
taxi the most efficient way of going
between these tillage and the financial
district and so it's not surprising that
then it's complementing the traditional
built in infrastructure home in city
public transit oh and so really the
central question that you we want to
build models is is if we think
we're not going to have much ability to
influence where bikes are during the
rush hour because any transmit you know
transit of bikes by vehicles during rush
hour has the same limitations of what
Manhattan is like so the main question
is no as I think about it what do I want
is stocking levels at the start of a
rush hour or in particular what I wanted
to start stocking level at 6am we'll
talk about other things that are done to
sort of mitigate the fact that used to
you know how you actually satisfy demand
over those heavy usage times but but
that's the center of the first question
that I want build a model to do and at
this point the models that we have for
around-the-clock invited targeted
inventory levels are or what actually
the city uses for defining what it
thinks the right the right amount at a
given station in a given time and as
much as we set these target levels they
aren't achieved I mean they're just is
in the operational costs in in achieving
these target levels Oh far exceed what
would be reasonable for further rhythm
to and so their various compromises that
get made and we've been working on
models to figure out exactly quand the
file ways to to deal with exactly those
trade-offs so here's the basic framework
that we're going to know take a step
back that thinking about this data in
the aggregate means that we can make
some simplifying assumptions you can use
historical data to approximate the both
the arrival traffic for picking up a
bike and the department leaving off
traffic for depositing a bike as poss on
flows oh and we'll make the reasonable
but perhaps not so reasonable we can
come talk about that later that these
are these are independent rates and so
this means that just to sort of get you
thinking about what the issue is that if
we know that there's a lot of flow from
penn station to the east 30s then if
Penn Station is out of bikes then of
course that's going to affect the
arrival rate as well so they're not in
pendant but for a first approximation
we're going to assume that and the idea
that we're going to use it the guiding
metric that we've used throughout all of
our models is that we want to minimize
the expected number of people that
arrive either to rent and there are no
bikes or the number of people who arrive
to return and there are no docks and the
sum of those okay so that's the
objective function we want to minimize
the expected value of that objective is
it one much worse than yoga yes one is
much worse than the other oh they did
you know if they've been on the other
hand if you have a bike and there isn't
a doc you will solve it you are on
wheels you'll go in the yo-yo you'll
write it to the nearby station and
indeed many of the things that we've
done is it has moved the city from
thinking about the quality of service
metrics from being targeted by stations
but by actually thinking about
neighborhoods so as to be sure that
those kinds of trade-offs get taken to
play account so I mean so we're in a
more explicitly we're going to have a
continuous time Markov chain Oh model
that ranging you know the states of the
Markov chain will range from that the
station is empty to the station is fully
at capacity in terms of the number of
bikes and that they're going to be
transitions depending on the arrival and
and and return arrival of renters in the
return of bikes there and and you know
that's if lambda is the rental rate mu
is the return rate we're going to have a
cost associated with stocking let's say
it's 6am and think about the planning
cycle of an 18 hour or let's say a 4
hour of planning cycle through the rush
hour of the cost of the expected number
of upset people given that we've stocked
the the station initially at I so a
little bit of notation X of X of T
denotes the state at times T it's
somewhere between zero and a given
capacity C and then if I just focus on
one of those two terms you know we're
going to compute the expected value of
the flow rate out this is an indicator
of the
currently the state is empty given that
the chain started in initial state I and
there's a collie nose symmetric term of
course for in terms of the computer I
mean one could discretize time but it
only makes the computations underlying
it messier I mean I know as computer
scientists that it's about to wear
natural thing that we could sort of
think about sort of self but essentially
you know otherwise you're going to be
modeling a lot of self loops of things
not changing and so if one thinks about
that objective function here are some of
the cost curves from a variety of yep
sir Sir just for one gong that that's
for one station one station that they're
doing so we have so so here I'm showing
you a variety of different stations and
different flow rates of what the
expected number of customers who arrived
without a bite without a doc and or
customer with the bike and want to
return without a docker want to rent in
there isn't a bike so I mean if you look
at these curves I mean it's not no means
no surprise this is a convex function oh
and oh that that means that if I think
about the system problem i have a fleet
of bikes of total number of bikes be and
i have i want to minimize the overall
upset cost of users across the system
and every allocation is going to be the
number of bikes that i put at a given
station as is going to be somewhere
between zero and the capacity of that
station okay so we have a convex
optimization problem in fact one can
prove it's not hard to prove that that
in fact this is this there's enough
structure there that we get integer
optimum so it's just kind of a sort of
convex allocation problem oh and so we
actually can solve this in fact what we
end up doing to solve it is that we
consider the lower envelope in the
function is only interesting on an
integer value so in fact we sort of have
a linear
words underneath that convex function
that we're really optimizing over and so
we're really solving a linear program
and then being a short in integer
optimum okay so so this gives you a
sense of of what we do and we had been
doing that we'd been planning to think
about the model over a 18 our planning
period and that we would then be using
where we are at the end of the day too
so this is this is it at midnight and
this is the target so this is load color
to coding loads indicating of where we
are and this is what actually happens
and the color coding indicates whether
we're close to the 6am optimum or not
and you'll see well there is some
improvement of what gets done by
removing by moving bikes overnight you
it's not that the the right map is
turning white and that we're really
getting close to the 6a a 6am targets in
terms of what happens landrum you can't
make how well can you project this so
the data gives us so first of all I mean
I'll talk about this at all sort of
steal my you know my next slide or two
slides down I'm making annoyed I put
there was actually a constant rate
Poisson process and that's definitely
not the case in that really made a case
that we were really thinking of planning
through one rush hour where we really
thought that it was reasonable to to
plan and we're going to talk about going
to time varying well-found rates in a
minute oh and for that there's an
interesting question of censoring in the
sense that i know i mean i know the
demand that gets used but i don't know
the demand a bit especially on the on
the rental I don't know the people who
didn't use the system because there
wasn't going to be available there
wasn't availability and the good thing
is that we can actually in some ways d
sensor the the data by taking advantage
of the fact that if I look at a given
10-minute time when window and I just
conditioned to understand the demand
raid over periods when there actually
were bikes available that gives a more
accurate estimate of latent demand but
overall I mean this is a human behavior
thing and people's behavior are being
influenced by their general expectation
of whether the service is available and
the extent to which it is getting used I
mean I'm quite sure if we build it they
will come kind of thing that there is an
effect almost infinite demand at Penn
Station oh that just to give you what
what actually happens at a given day the
now is that every night we pull out of
circulation an extra between 500 and
thousand bikes that's out of the total
pool of 7,000 and they get stored in a
depo immediately adjacent to Penn
Station originally was used to try to
quickly shuttle bikes back and forth
between that Depot and the the nearest
legitimate station and now they just
send up a temporary station that people
just come there and it's an interesting
process to watch at what point during
the morning does however many bikes they
were able to pull out of the rest of the
systems as exhaust so what's the real
that mean so what is the real demand and
that's that's you know an interesting
sort of both estimation but also a
behavior question in terms of how to
really think about it so the current
ability to rebalance simply just doesn't
move enough bikes so one can ask another
question of now the way these stations
are built are actually in modules of two
and three the of docks so the fact that
some original design decision was made
in order to how many docs should be at a
given station we can actually go back to
the same convex program and instead of
thinking about these as being input that
to the problem we could think of them as
being variables and then there will be
an additional you know budget constraint
on the total number of docs in the
system and now we can ask the question
of is there are there better ways to
allocate both
bikes and docks together and this was
was something that we did again for the
constant rate and we followed exactly on
the same framework the math isn't as
nice it's still we still have nice
joined convexity now that we sort of
have both bikes and docks and the kinds
of variables that were going to be
interested in now the linear program
that is sort of this lower envelope of
the convex program I know long because
in some sense there are two of these
knapsack like constraints Oh that we no
longer have the integrality result at
least we don't know that we have the
integrality result from a practical
point of view when I solve that convex
program I get integers so and we'll see
that at least from a complexity point of
view that's not not so surprising that
I'll talk them in a minute about a
direct combinatorial algorithm to solve
that optimization problem but I mean
another question is no is this know how
much is our modeling assumption really
affecting things they in particular
let's ask this question about the
independence assumption about those
rates Oh being completely you know
stated is given without without
dependencies as I as I think about it so
a natural way it is to consider instead
a simulation simulation optimization
perspective and we can model you know
exactly these stochastic processes and
and and and have a functioning system
and see what kinds of performance we can
get and indeed that we get better
allocations of a if I think about
running the simulation on the optimized
computed based on the the static model
we get can substantially improve it by
doing some local optimization with
respect to the original bike allocations
and this is just in the the bike
allocation mode and so it's an
interesting question of whether we can
actually make the continuous time Markov
chains better and of course another
glaring pieces this was all back in the
constant rate regime another thing to
think about is when you think about the
difference between the simulation
optimization model and what our cost
curves give us is that one thing that
the kind one thing that we want is
perhaps and indeed now how it's used is
we while I focus by saying what's the
right inventory at 6am and then we're
going to use it through a given period
of time it's actually in terms of the
day to day in real time operations
currently being used of as I look at the
system now and I can compute the
analogous um desired inventory level at
a given snapshot within the day um how
far off am I from what I believe the
right inventory level are and you know
and this this this comes in the
operation and indeed what you again the
the Twitter feed shows all kinds of
people objecting to decisions that
aren't quite the right thing so let's
look at some data just so we go to send
so here i'm going to show you i'm
showing you a week's or five days worth
of plots at a station here at 27th and
First Avenue and on the y axis we have
the number of bikes in a given station
and we have the 24-hour clock here okay
so one thing you can see is that well
you can see the difference between
weekdays and weekends in a very stark
way here we have that's a weekend day
here we have a weekday oh but even if I
was thinking about the assumption that
within a given rush hour six to ten am I
had constants rental and return rates
that's profoundly false for this station
on on a weekday now yes this is the
worst station in the system for
displaying the lack of that behavior in
fact it's outside bellevue hospital and
what we're seeing in all likelihood is
people arriving to work at 8am and then
the overnight nursing shift in other
parts of the hospital administration
leaving so that that we have both
inflows and outflows right from the same
location pretty much turning out that
eight o'clock but nonetheless if you
look sort of station by station the
constant rate even
within a given rush hour is is
questionable so we don't see time and
Varian rates here's another station
Hudson and read and actually this was
the the value that we think about mean
these are values set by the the original
morning rush dominated Markov chain and
one thing we just see is that although
there are these large number of Doc's we
really just don't need these that number
of Doc's here I mean that you that that
the variability within a given day is
not such that that you're hitting both
extremes that you just sort of have a
much more limited bandwidth of
variability so so it's natural then to
go ahead to a more sophisticated model
we're going to delineate the day into it
distinct time intervals where just
within that let's say 30 minute time
interval we're going to assume a
constant rate but we want to then extend
the same methodology to to handle that
and of course that will make the problem
more complex and that even just solving
the linear program for that will be a
stress on the system so in some sense
there are three challenges we want to
generalize the time during rates we want
to there's this concern about the linear
program versus the integer program when
I'm thinking about both doc and bike and
and I for a variety of reasons will want
to have a more efficient running time so
this is the more general model that that
I now have a number of intervals across
the day with different rates that will
evolve and I'm going to do a slight
change of variables I'm going to be
thinking about in an allocation
allocating a number of bikes in a
station and a number of empty docks okay
so rather than thinking of as the total
number of docs and and and they're just
clearly a nice linear transformation and
so now the states will range between 0
and and the total allocation full and
empty docks and we can have a now
function but we can extend the the
machinery by sort of standard stochastic
dynamic programming in order to compute
the cost functions over the course of a
series of piecewise constant plus on
rates because if I know the expected
number of upset customers for any given
station for any given a stocking level
then if I want and I for the last t
minus K periods and I want to extend
that back to know for the last t minus k
plus 1 periods then I simply need to
take understand the probability of
evolving from an input of B bikes to an
input of to a resulting state of beta
bikes and then the cost for the K minus
1 interval is the cost of everything
from from from that interval on plus the
probabilistic Lee weighted cost to go of
that one interval and of course this was
the things that we could compute for
just one interval and so it's just
extending the same machinery in a nice
dynamic programming kind of setting so
so we can compute these cost functions
and now the clean and nice result is
that in fact one can solve this
simultaneous bike and allocation problem
by a direct greedy algorithm of a
somewhat non-trivial structure but but
it's not too hard to prove so the idea
is that we initially put all stations
there no empty docks and no bikes
anywhere you have a pool of FMT docks
and a pool of bikes to allocate while
you have both bikes and doc you find the
best place to either put a bike in a
dock in terms of improving your cost
function or the place an empty dock
wherever that's improvement if in the
end what the thing that limits you of
having both bikes and docks is the you
no Doc's left you end otherwise will you
still have additional docs you either
add an empty dock or together take an
empty dock with moving one of the
existing bikes wherever you get the most
improvement so here's a maybe a rather
than words pictures probably work better
initially you haven't allocated anything
anywhere you have a collection of bikes
and a collection of docks oh and either
you're going to allocate an empty dock
or a bike in a dock to a station
wherever the improvement in the overall
cost of the system is is greatest there
are two ways in which this land where
you have docs left but no bikes or bikes
left when you have no docks in the first
case you check well what can I do to
improve the system by allocating an
additional empty dock to one of my
stations in the or if I allocate a one
of those docs and I move a bike from
where it currently is and leave that
empty dock somewhere else okay the
realistic model for the design or
actually for operations where you can
actually move empty dock surface so so
this is an first of all this is an
algorithm to solve in polynomial time
the stochastic optimization problem of
choosing the best allocation of bikes
and docs system-wide okay so this is
something that given an annual review
the system goes down basically in over
the winter months when one could do
movements of bikes to from a will of the
docs from the current configuration to
next year's configuration this this is
the moving docsis you know they're there
to know hundreds of pounds kind of thing
you need a crane to lift it up this is
this is move move move a small number of
Doc's of every square foot in
looking for how you added up so one has
to actually add no box constraints on
what for every given station you know
what's what's the limit on the the size
of that station and that's doable as
well within the same framework and if
you only have bikes left than you
terminate the key thing I won't go into
it is a kind of two dimensional version
of sub-module arity that that holds for
functions of this sword that o is a
concept known as multi modularity that
was introduced by Bruce Hayek I won't go
through the underlying mathematics to of
that but but but nonetheless this this
is sort of the structural property of
what our cost functions have that that
have and it has essentially the
decreasing marginal returns in a number
in in fact three different dimensions
even though they're only to explicitly
here and I won't talk about the proof at
all but claimed that that indeed it's
not too hard to show that the algorithm
that I just described does to produce
the optimal allocation so we've gone
from a setting where we were thinking
about things in terms of constant plus
on rates versus this time varying plus
on rates and also the sort of questions
of both are we just allocating bikes
reallocating bikes and docks simulation
optimization improve the bike
allocations in the constant rate what
happens here now we've done improved in
two dimensions it's really thinking
about both the bike and dock allocation
and the fact that we have time varying 0
0 plus on rates the analogous simulation
optimization rather than before we got
twenty percent improvement now we could
only get three percent improvement and
of course the fact that we're using it
you know running this greedy algorithm
rather than solving this LP we're using
about two percent of the the running
time in order to actually compute the
results the second example I showed you
which were but somehow not being managed
right Oh is an interesting case in that
oh it's very clear that that although
you're allocating this large number of
Doc's they're not really getting used
and one thing that that highlighted for
us in and I'll loop back to this is one
can try to understand that in operating
the system motivate spends a tremendous
amount of money moving bikes overnight
and one can ask the question of is it
worth it oh you know that you don't make
that much in the way of improvements now
it has to be very careful in building
that model because things like this
depot outside penn station play a
critical role in terms of the
performance of the system oh but one
thing you can compare it to is what I'd
call a steady-state analysis so as you
think about this model rather than just
running it for 1 18 hour period from 6am
to 12 midnight and untried understand
how that system evolves and what the
costs are now just repeat ad infinitum
what would be how would the system work
and evolve I in terms of thinking about
solving what's going on we can really
extend the same kinds of tools all and
now we can even you know think about
really what's happening this is an
embedded Markov chain for which we
understand the limiting distribution and
can therefore do the the cost analysis
so here's a table that compares a number
of strategies in terms of what the
optimization results show so on the one
hand if we optimally allocate bikes and
docks and we do the full rebalancing
between 12 midnight and 6am which is you
know tremendously expensive
the expected number of upset customers
in it in the next 18 hours is something
around 9300 okay in contrast to that if
i allocate bikes and docks according to
what the steady-state behavior looks
like and i dunno rebalancing i just
initialize the system but I've allocated
the docks in anticipation that I'm not
going to do any rebalancing I'm at
11,000
but to give a sense of how bad the
current allocation is even if I did
optimal rebalancing so I did absolutely
everything for the way the docs are
currently laid out in terms of where
they are in the city I have 12,000
expected upset customers on a daily
basis so doing nothing in rebalancing
for the right configuration of docs
gives me better performance than doing
absolutely perfect rebalancing for what
the current system currently has and of
course we're currently trying to nudge
Oh citibike to sort of grapple with the
fact that that they may want to do the
political Wars of what it's needed of
what that would mean to actually move to
that dock allocation from where things
currently are this is a daily number
that's a lot of I mean so the system is
very stress is the system is really
under cap at me and that's another
immuno important takeaway the system is
under capacitated in a huge way I mean
another way of saying that the system is
under capacity I either is massive
demand I even if you treat your people
badly you're going to get lots of
customers yes so the question is if I
treated twice as badly should I really
care now Harry that's it when you talk
about daily lube dancing what would be
the costume dollars of rebalancing and I
guess to relate that to the cost of
unhappy customers do they view the
revenue from people hiring them as a
revenue stream or they're just view it
as as peanuts compared to the benefit on
the transit network so first of all
important and and I'm badly misjudging
time so I'll try to so one important
thing this is this is a private
profit-seeking entity that has a quality
of service contract with the city of New
York so the question of how I mean their
goal as a company is too
is to is to make sure they're enough
subscribers to help pay the bills now
there's an understanding that so the
same umbrella company motivate runs bike
sharing companies in a large number of
North American cities the investors are
actually based in New York and they care
more about the performance in New York
um and are willing to let New York be a
loss leader oh in terms of what
operations do but to move one bike and
then we'll say a little bit about
incentives and other sorts of things of
their to move 11 bike costs at least
dollar / / / bike moved so it's it's
it's very expensive oh and in contrast
to that an annual subscriber for all you
can eat and i'll put the up in a second
pays a hundred and fifty five dollars
for the full year's usage so there's no
question that there are a whole host of
users that are for whom their annual
subscription does not pay the
rebalancing cost just for their for
their own use their own use let alone
the optimal it alone the the actual
physical entity of suppose as opposed to
buying that so the expected cost of a
bike in New York is pretty high because
it gets stolen you also don't have room
to put it in your apartment and what's
more it involve a button and perhaps the
no fundamental thing that makes it
really important is it allows different
modes of transit in different directions
yes I use the bike shed but else it's
gonna rain in the morning I walk or take
a bus and then it's nice i come back i
mean our operational nightmare is the
late the very rare summer late afternoon
thunderstorm which of course is in there
because it means that you've had this
tremendously a symmetric flow which puts
bikes you know where people work and
then all of a sudden nobody rides it
going back because there and somehow or
other something has to be done overnight
and really what happens is not so much
service in tel aviv but when it was a
novelty was used a lot and then demand
just the cave so a typical bike in New
York I mean gets used eight times on
average no no I per day I mean yeah
that's so for example I mean one thing
so so if you look at the the
steady-state analysis that we did and we
asked where does that no don't worry
about rebalancing but to get get the
done doc allocation right red means take
out Doc's blue beans put put more docs
there this is politically impossible it
just means essentially strip Brooklyn of
all head queens of all of its stocks
because it's just not getting the same
level of usage but nonetheless it's
really I mean you could maybe say that
where this is just a political
investment the real question is getting
you know what would it take in terms of
additional docs to to bring the
Manhattan levels to that to that point
ok she movable stations yeah point is
that I you know I heard this cook guy
talk about tradition pasta so high and
we're bus costs are so high they're
moving warehouses drives through San
Paolo motorcycle day so we do it I mean
so there's a notion of a corral which
its first implement were there things
that are called valets and Corral's the
first implementation were either chain
bikes to a tree and have someone there
to to actually you know be able to
extend the capacity of a station the
more sophisticated things are called
Corral's we're in effect because if you
looked at this the pictures there's a
fair amount of space between all there
and so again if you have an attendant
you happy so those are our movable
depots I mean so there we know that
there are I mean the old post office
building is what gets used as a piece of
for this large number of bikes that are
handle opposite the penn station and and
but there aren't equally things but a
box truck of 50 is only a box truck of
50 and with in rush hour moving those
box trucks of capacity 50 is it self
limiting so you can about double the
capacity you want to do it in a station
because it's going to take an attendant
in order to actually handle that so you
aligning it with there already are
stations and what the map means is is
psychologically a better thing but all
of these these games have been played to
try to have more variable capacity
new bikes yeah so in my non-existent I'm
let me say Lee so this was mostly about
the operations of just trying to
understand the have a good model for how
many bikes should be at a station in a
given time but there a variety of other
interesting operational questions if
we're going to do overnight route
routing how do you actually do that
efficiently and it's just an interesting
new model of a vehicle routing problem
the first version when they had really
bad crews the crews could not take any
instruction about how many bikes to pick
up and how many bikes to drop off so we
ended up giving them simpler
instructions which we were just fill the
truck with bikes from that station drive
to this station and empty the truck and
put all the bikes there and so that was
our overnight rebalancing one the crews
have gotten better so we can give them
more sophisticated feeds the way in
which mid rush rebalancing gets handled
predominantly is that they built bicycle
trailers that so a pedicab that can fit
out can hold five or six city bikes on
its back and then can be bicycle back
and forth between two nearby stations
one which has too many bikes and one
which has too few and then we just
designate pairings and they go back and
forth and so there were nice facility
location style optimization problems
that can get solved to determine how
that gets done I mentioned these
Corral's of putting additional people so
that you have this movable extra
capacity how you actually pull when you
have a the ability to have a few of them
how do you place them this is is
something that we've worked with them on
and then one thing that's really just in
the last six weeks there is now a bike
angels program of and this is by far and
away the most likely to change bad
finances to a workable model is
incentive schemes to get around the fact
that the city's pricing on framework is
as dumb as can be in that it's just all
driven by annual thing so just to give
you sense this is the current pricing
scheme you can buy twelve dollars 40
one day passed or twenty-four dollars
for a three-day pass you can ride for 30
minutes for free for those and then to
take as many rides afterwards or 155
dollars for really every everything once
so those traders in the East Village
that are commuting the financial
district are getting quarter rides for
their commute rather than you know 275
what it takes to ride the subway so yeah
and this is what I mentioned before that
rebalancing alone exceeds if you look at
sort of the usual 8020 curve the twenty
percent of the subscribers are doing
eighty percent that actually it's more
like 10 and ninety-two ten percent of
the users are doing ninety percent of
the rides those ten percent are not
paying for you they're rebalancing costs
alone in time that I don't have I'll
just allude to stuff that Sid won't be
talking about but recent work with the
to Cornell students on on some demand
driven pricing models of which I guess
you can ask either us about in the break
there are a number of ongoing things one
thing that that there's sort of this
myth that for every the ratio of docs in
the system to bikes should be two to one
every system is set up pretty much with
that ratio there's there's no scientific
basis for this whatsoever and in
particular in a model where you're
pulling Depot's out so you can have a
way of sort of you know putting
additional capacity in a surge way it's
clear that that's not the right thing so
we're going to that's one nice thing of
how to use our simulation optimization
tools there are crazy operational things
so in New York the station's run on
solar power as opposed to in Tel Aviv
where they're on the grid which of
course makes no sense whatsoever so this
means that the two car batteries like
things which really don't get recharged
by solar have to be replaced on on
somewhere between two to three week
intervals and just actually maintaining
that
this is an interesting operational
challenge in terms of keeping the system
going we're giving them new tools to do
better overnight rebalancing now that
their crews do better and one really
nice problem that's evolved over we've
given them some help on and there's
better things to be done is that when a
bike moves into a dock there's a
handshake protocol to pin that bike into
the dock okay so and there's really
detailed information about what happens
when there's an attempt and whether it
actually succeeds but you have this very
sparse set of triples of doc ID bike ID
and user ID and when you have failures
like this and then you're trying to I
mean the are you supposed to pull that
find that bike and pull it out of
circulation are you supposed to go in
plug and play the new new doc are you
supposed to send the user a new
instructional video by email so they do
a better job of actually locking their
bike into place and actually trying to
use make you know headway with that day
this is sort of an interesting thing
we've been working on recently I mean in
general this is just the ripe for a
range of data analytic questions but the
message I want to conclude with is sort
of tying it back to real-time decision
making is that having the model to know
a measure for thinking about how many
bikes should be at each station is
really sort of the groundwork for then
being able to do the kind of real-time
decision making that actually now
actually gets done by by hands of a
dispatcher recognizing that a station is
way off from where it should be and then
we give them an automatic tool to say
where should you be pulling bikes and
sending a crew to pull the bikes from
the current system out and replenish
this stuff so that gives you a sense of
a range of different things we've been
doing and I'm happy to take questions
so yeah you kind of mentioned about
incentivization cut so I guess you said
she needs like always new one right and
one free space in each stage and then
essentially problem solved so good in
salou there's two to question that
hazard said one is like you know I guess
you can just charge based on occupancy
and then you're paying the price of the
person who can fight it's so this is why
incentives are such an important
mechanism in that this is a contract
that motivate has with the city of New
York chain the annual subscription fee
of a hundred and some odd dollars for
all-you-can-eat will not go away this
will be part of the contract come hell
or high water or at least until there's
a very different administration and so
then you mean incentives gives the
mechanism for introducing an effect an
alternative currency um and and then and
really what you want to do is you want
to shape behavior so I mean if you could
know if you think I mean one of the new
ways in which the city is is different
than most cities is that the cobbling
between residential and commercial is
much more intertwined oh and so you do
have lots of pairs of nearby stations
where one is saturated with bikes and
one is starved so you know it's not
Singapore where we can know promote the
healthiness of walking that last block
but if we can you know still provide the
incentives so that people can if nothing
else will get that they're over time
their subscription is paid or that then
that gives a way of doing that yeah
second questions like why don't you just
open capacitating system in terms of
numbers of bikes rather than moving
overnight just so you have to be careful
of bikes I'll just remove them from the
network over capacitate so that they
still come through
the next half so there is a delicate
balancing act that just as the so the
first footprint that I showed you in the
movie only went up to 57th Street and
the new bikes for the further expansion
into queens and brooklyn and up the
Upper East Side West Side actually
arrive before the expansion was complete
and so there was a brief period where
they had more bike well more bikes in
this two to one ratio but what then was
happening is that there were many more
instances of the 22 docks for everyone
bike like three bites for every two dogs
and they just take them out well so then
so you have to be able what do you do I
mean and where do they go right okay so
so so the point is that someone pointed
out that it's not symmetric in terms of
how upset a person is if they arrive and
there's no bike they're just take public
transit but if they've got this bike and
they've got to get rid of it and there
isn't anything in the neighborhood and
this has no it's not like this is a rare
phenomenon oh man going from one side to
the other you can just say let's have
three times as many bikes as there are
not but there is rather than over the
night just cart during the day take out
those but there is all kinds of
predictable stochasticity right so I
know when the storms are coming so I'm
going to leave work earlier to be able
to bike there all of a sudden you get
the surge of traffic which which you
then have to be coordinating with in in
real time yeah everything's expensive
you can just now they're cheaper there
no you can't sorry take that's real
estate that comes from the city I mean
the one what is this city this no the
company is delivers it has a qos
contract with city what are they getting
from the city they're getting the real
estate on which to put those those
things so I mean in effect that's what
they're doing with these Corral's but
together you know think about by
training programs in the case of New
York City it started out with Steve I'm
putting personal a dollars for that I
spent space this 4049 what we put
rounded ok
everything 101 so the second round of in
bed the second round was another 60 so
it's a hundred between the gym if you
you know look for sponsors or incentive
programs we talked briefly about this
but you know when I spoke to the city
white folks I'm suggesting it needs to
get somewhere things like that would be
quite powerful motivator I mean in fact
one thing which I don't understand why
their marketing department isn't better
is that the one idea that we gave them
is that it's easy to identify large
employers that are in anti flow
locations if we could you know we would
be happy to for a very small fee that is
really nothing give employees no
memberships provided that those are sort
of restricted memberships that they can
use it to go to and from work so you can
use it to go to work as much what you
can certainly use it from work seeing my
value city backs all namely get
replacement value
the new round of investors I always
forget the name but it's this very
upscale health club and that was their
intent in adding the the second round of
capital was that they thought they were
going to integrate it within their their
health club regime um but yeah I mean
that's certainly an important piece but
maybe I should let people have a break
into and to take questions off 10 is a
pretty much